do not have a legal basis to remain will
be placed in expedited removal
proceedings
dhs is conducting regular expulsion and
removal flights to haiti mexico ecuador
and northern triangle countries
we are very concerned that haitians who
are taking this irregular migration path
are receiving false information that the
border is open or that temporary
protected status is available i want to
make sure that it is known that this is
not the way to come to the united states
that is false information
irregular migration poses a serious
security risk to the migrants themselves
trying to enter the united states
illegally
is not worth the tragedy
the money
or the effort as we have said
consistently since we published the
federal register notice officially
officially designating haiti for
temporary protected status or gps
only haitians living in the united
states before july 29
are eligible for temporary protected
status
we have reiterated that our borders are
not open and people should not make the
dangerous journey
individuals
and families are subject to border
restrictions
including expulsion irregular migration
poses a significant threat
to the health and welfare welfare of
border communities and to the lives of
the migrants themselves and should not
be attempted
if you come to the united states
illegally you will be returned
your journey will not succeed and you
will be endangering your life
and your family's lives
this administration is committed to
developing safe
orderly and humane pathways for
migration but this is not the way to do
it
thank you it is my pleasure to introduce
commissioner troy miller of the united
states board of protection
good afternoon thank you mr secretary
thank you for joining us here today
and importantly thank you for what
you've done over the last several days
to elevate the work that we're doing
so this group
since this group of migrants began
arriving in del rio your leadership has
ensured that dhs could count on a whole
government approach
that is not just a buzzword it means
that the federal government has engaged
in mobilizing the necessary resources to
process
the migrants arriving here at del rio
quickly humanely and maintain the safety
of everyone involved
i can't say thank you enough
to the state local ngo partners that are
also here
with us
once again everybody's come together to
assist in addressing the needs of the
local communities while also addressing
the challenging situations we face
together i thank you for everyone's hard
work
i also want to thank
my colleague
border patrol chief
ortiz
she took the helm a few short weeks ago
and just in time to lead this important
important effort in his hometown
the chief will give additional
operational details in just a minute
and i want to thank the cbp workforce
who continue to rally to every situation
and challenge we face
i am proud to work alongside the
dedicated and resilient men and women of
cbp every single day
who serve this country with relentless
determination and integrity
finally i want to stress something
important cbp's message for anyone
thinking of entering the united states
illegally along the southern border is
clear and simple
our borders are not open entering
entering the country
illegally as spain is a dangerous
undertaking don't put your life or put
your family's safety in the hands of
smugglers or other criminals who will
tell you that our borders are open don't
do it
with that i want to turn it over
to
eos board control t
good morning and thank you acting
commissioner miller and secretary
mayorkas for the support you provided so
we can get these resources moved in here
as quickly as we have the coordination
within cbp throughout dhs and across the
federal government is key to our
response this really has been a holy
government approach
as i've never seen before and that means
it has included our state local ngo
partners and certainly the communities
that have come together and worked long
hours to address this situation here in
del rio texas and i want to thank them
uh from the bottom of my heart i also
want to talk a little bit about you know
what we have mobilized
as the commissioner the secretary
mentioned
600 agents that includes uh customs
officers and border patrol agents mobile
field force trained individuals
and dhs volunteer force personnel to the
derail sector to improve control of the
situation underneath this bridge we
prioritize surgery medical support
personnel and have expanded the scope
and scale of medical support on the
ground this includes the cbp mts dhs
volunteer force members as well as
personnel from across the federal
government to include the hhs the
disaster medical assistance team who
arrived this morning and are continuing
to provide services to the migrants
this also includes the san antonio fire
department they sent personnel to assist
us and we want to thank all of these
partners for the assistance as we
provide integrated on-site medical
services and try to reduce the strain on
the local community together our teams
have been able to handle most medical
concerns while continue to stay in touch
with local health systems on issues that
may require
additional medical care at a facility
here in del rio
the general port of entry remains closed
traffic is being rerouted from del rio
to eagle pass to more effectively
managed resources and ensure under
uninterrupted flow of trade and travel
as i said yesterday
u.s border patrol is coordinating with
immigration and customs enforcement and
the u.s coast guard to move individuals
from del rio to other processing
locations within texas
including 2500
on sunday
dhs is also working to accelerate and
increase the frequency and capacity of
title 42 flags to expel individuals to
haiti and other countries of
origin we're achieving our goals we're
getting there and getting to a point
where we can manage a population here we
are already seeing it quickly diminish
and we'll continue to see that over the
coming days
i talked yesterday
about how so much of this migration is
driven through social media and word of
mouth
and smugglers are significant drivers of
the misinformation
that gets people to undertake these
dangerous journeys
smugglers continue to recklessly
endanger lives of individuals they
exploit for their own financial gain
many of these migrants cross through
remote harsh terrain and unpredictable
weather to get this far
many likely
didn't make it
the smugglers leverage misinformation to
mislead people
some of that information is focused on
the tps
let's be clear
only those
living in the united states
prior to july 29
are eligible for temporary protected
status or tps
no one who arrived here this past week
will be eligible to get tps
so here's the fact
we are still enforcing the cdc title 42
order and those attempting irregular
migration here will not be allowed to
enter the united states
they will be removed and sent back to
the country of origin as mandated under
current laws
i also want to stress that for those
being removed to haiti
our partners at the state department are
working to ensure
that there is adequate support when they
arrive
in haiti
but the message is clear
do not attempt the journey
all of you coming here for the media
you're crucial to getting this message
out that the smugglers are unscrupulous
and the misinformation is wrong
our borders are not open
and people should not make the journey
thank you for being here
thank you mr secretary for being here my
question is in regards to um thank you
for what you're doing right now we see a
lot of action right now but this took
four to five days why did it take so
long as those numbers continued to grow
and uh you know you knew they were
coming uh so the um the volume of people
uh was rather sudden rather dramatic
very quick and we surged resources
according to the
may i ask you pace do you respond to
those who say that these ancient
immigrants are being sent back
back to some really bad conditions
faster than others
so that is
factually uh inaccurate let me say
something with respect to the fact that
individuals are being returned uh to
haiti specifically
what we did is we
studied the country conditions in haiti
to determine whether temporary protected
status was warranted
when we were going to publish the
federal register notice announcing tps
several months ago
the tragic assassination of the haitian
leader occurred
we withheld publication of that notice
to see what the country conditions would
be following the assassination what the
level and extent and duration of any
unsettlement was
we watched that we saw a new government
uh take power uh we published
accordingly uh the federal register
notice and announced that tps was
available for people in the united
states as of july 29th
we were accommodating to the conditions
in the country as is our legal
obligation to do so
we then saw the tragic and devastating
earthquake
in haiti
that earthquake as tragic and
devastating as it is
and was
is distinct from the january 10 2010
earthquake that was not as
geographically limited as this one is
we made an assessment based on the
country conditions as we are required to
do that a redesignation of haiti was not
warranted on the facts on the conditions
in haiti that haiti could in fact
receive individuals safely tps is
available to those who have been in the
united states
before july 29th and that is not
changing
all right
secretary
uh kev olisina with cbs 11 dallas fort
worth thanks for being here i just
wanted to sort of pick you back a little
bit on what colleen mentioned here she
mentioned in the past couple of days but
uh for many of us who've been reporting
on this situation for months now we know
that border officials have been sort of
setting off alarms sending red flags to
washington saying we need help we need
help why is it taking so long for you
all to sort of dedicate this amount of
attention to resources to the border
finally after we see what's happening in
that bridge as i mentioned
before the surge in resources has been
commensurate with the surge in migration
mr secretary pedro broadcast with
univision national news uh welcome
welcome to the border i i want to ask
you after you saw what you saw what was
touring the the shelter under the bridge
what impacted you the most and is there
a way that you think this could not
replicate because we have heard that
there are groups similar to this when
coming to reynosa tamaulipas and
possibly mccallum will see the same
scenario in the next few days so so let
me um let me answer the second part of
your question uh first and then the the
profound question you posed
at the outset
we are communicating as we have now for
months
loudly and clearly
that irregular migration the perilous
journey
is not the journey to take one risks
one's life the life of one's loved ones
for a mission that will not succeed
we have been we are and we will continue
to exercise the public health authority
of the centers for disease control in
light of the fact that this country and
this world
is confronting a pandemic
number one number two
i saw many different things when i
visited uh the bridge earlier today it's
not the first time that i've revisited
the bridge during my tenure
first and foremost let me speak of the
heartbreak
because it is tragic to see families
vulnerable individuals who've been
deceived by treacherous and exploitative
uh
smuggling organizations it is tragic and
it is heartbreaking
i also
see once again the heroic work of the
united states border patrol
of field operations of our state and
local partners and everyone in civil
society also
coming to the rescue to address the
needs of this population
as we execute our border authorities as
we are required to do to meet the
challenge mr secretary can you describe
the conditions currently as of saturday
and sunday people were able to stream
somewhat
on at will back and forth the dam is now
closed but further down river folks have
been able to
effectively go back and forth do you
have operational control of this stretch
of border
we we do and the decision with respect
to the movement of people is a
calculated decision to meet the
operational needs and to serve our
operational control
marcia
mr secretary so you stated repeatedly
that this is a challenge but last month
you were recorded privately saying that
what's been happening along the border
has unsustainable and admitting that
there's a crisis so i'm asking would you
publicly admit right now when you make
it privately that would happen
i'm going to stop you right there let me
just say very clearly
we are focused on meeting the challenge
we are focused on mission
so this this is this oh i'm sorry i
didn't mean to interrupt please this is
certainly distinct from the other
large movements of migrants that we have
observed and to which we've responded
i'm going to let chief ortiz provide
more detail
as most of you all know i was the deputy
and the chief in rgb for five and a half
years and so the big difference is one
this is a much smaller community than
the rio grande valley so the capacity
both of the
cbp and some of the other agencies and
partners is much smaller secondly uh
this was a very rapid uh surge across
the border what we see in rgb which
continues to be the busiest place in the
country has been steady throughout the
year but del rio over the last six or
seven months has seen an uptick in
traffic and we continue to move
resources into the area but
more importantly than this they
concentrated in one location in south
texas they spread out over multiple
locations and so that is the primary
difference between the two we have time
for two more sandra and then over here
good afternoon mr secretary um
could you respond to texas governor greg
abbott's letter sent to the bible
administration today requesting a
federal declaration for emergency be
declared for the entire state of texas
based on what's happening um uh so we
evaluate uh requests for such a
declaration
based on the facts on the ground we will
treat uh this request no differently
hi secretary julian garcia with the
texas tribune um
images have come out of border patrol
agents with communication immigrants so
my question to you do you think that's a
humane way to treat migrants uh you are
assuming the facts if i may say
respectfully uh you were assuming facts
uh that uh not yet been determined um
chief ortiz is an experienced border
patrol
agent
who has ridden horses trained others to
ride horses can provide greater detail
on the specifics
i will tell you that the horse patrol
units down here are going to play an
integral part in the security response
as you know
we have about half of this area
locked down and we're working on trying
to get the other side of the bridge
completely locked down and so what i
asked our horse patrol units to do
yesterday is to do an assessment and
find out if we had any individuals in
distress and to be able to provide
information and intelligence as to what
the smuggling organizations were doing
in and around the river as was witnessed
in the video in some of the pictures the
migrants were going back and forth we do
not know who are the smugglers or who
are the migrants so it's important that
those border patrol agents maintain a
level of security for both themselves
and for the migrant population as they
were trafficking back and forth but as
the secretary mentioned i've ridden
horses for several years operating in
the riverine environment on horseback is
a difficult situation and trying to
making control of those horses so we do
not get in a position where we injure a
migrant as they're trying to make that
treacherous trek across that river is
probably more important than anything
and i'm pretty sure and confident that
that's exactly what was happening but we
will certainly look into the matter to
make sure that
we do not have any activity that could
be construed as a
a response to a law enforcement effort
that is unacceptable
thank you
yeah and and just to add because chief
ortiz explained to me that to um
to ensure control uh of the horse long
reigns are used but we are going to
investigate the facts to ensure uh that
the situation is as we understand it to
be and if it's anything different we
will respond accordingly
that could be any number of you
uh will you be requesting assistance
from the department of defense uh there
is obviously law enforcement is
overwhelmed here so you plan on asking
assistance from the dod so it's a very
good question because
in fact
the approach has been in all of federal
government uh effort and frankly in all
the federal government effort in
partnership with state and local
authorities and with civilization
society and the department of defense is
evaluating a request for assistance and
we hope that will
come to fruition very shortly
we just want to thank you for for being
here this is
a very difficult
situation for us uh it is
extraordinarily challenging as i said at
the outset it is very very heartbreaking
we are meeting the challenge we are
addressing the vulnerabilities of the
individuals we are
surging resources not only
uh to ensure uh the security of this
area the security of the community
but also the well-being of the migrants
themselves to address their needs
their food needs their water needs their
medical needs and any other needs that
they might have thank you so much for
being here
i'll be right here
you